welcome back to glamour and filtered
pasted by me Josh Nick and today we're
joined by in my personal pee the queen
of the power ballad it's honestly um I
have been an emotional roller coaster
this has been really hard as a working
parent because I'm still doing all the
same jobs obviously I'm not doing makeup
but I'm doing a tiny bit of hair I'm
like but I'm just doing all the the jobs
and it's just it's been exhausting
honestly plus you know cooking every
meal and cleaning non-stop after
toddlers and teenagers and I'm trying to
be a healthy distraction for everyone
and it gets old seeing the same
sweatshirt you know over and over so
like all the things are crazy
yeah what's so interesting about this
time is well I guess is that there's so
much pressure on you to be like this
stare home um whilst being a working mom
how is your relationship with this idea
of being a good working mom changed and
how is it been so much pressure on you
around that as well as you've gone
through your career we're lucky in a lot
of senses we are fortunate so I'm not
complaining in that sense but I
definitely had to remind people that I
work with like look you hired a mom and
and I'm a not an absentee mom like I'm
not full-on mom so um and I don't want
to you know I already have abandonment
issues I don't want to pass those down
so um because I guess as well like the
whole element of abandonment issues like
that's such a hard thing to place on
yourself have you have you gained a
better relationship with the idea oh
yeah I mean I think you know I don't
think you get rid of that I don't think
that you ever it's almost like you know
I have people in my life that stuff for
from addiction to certain things and and
that doesn't go away it's always there
it's just navigating your life around
that existence in your life so you don't
ever like one day wake up and are like
okay I'm totally cool with the fact that
I have major bantam issues cuz there's
you know horrible things happens out of
all of that you've got to recognize at
some point though that it's made you who
you are so thankful in a sense that you
know I'm a very strong individual I'm
very
I've been forced to find that myself
I've been forced to you know at a very
early age so at some point I say thank
you you know to my father who passed
away last year but but I thank him in a
sense of like you know I wouldn't have
become this I don't think I wouldn't
have been able to be all that I am right
now without all of that it's always
gonna present itself
you know you get married and you're like
oh I have no one for the dance or taught
me down the aisle you know I'm not gonna
get married just gonna look like you
know there's always things that that
happen to come up that kind of bum you
out I don't think that's actually such a
powerful message to say to people you
can be negative situations and
ultimately those negativities and that
negative situation would ultimately
empower you as well right
if you want it to because I also have
friends that have had similar
backgrounds and they go the other way
and they're always in a self-pity victim
mode and it's like you know you can sit
here and cry about it all day long but
it's not gonna help you and you're not
hurting anyone but yourself I think it's
a choice it's a choice would have
whatever cards are dealt what you do
with them
I'm then learning to love yourself as
well as which is such an empowering
thing to do and that's a new single is
all about loving yourself which is what
we need to teach more people to do how
is your relationship with this idea in
this crazy concept of self-love changed
do you think through your life until you
can love yourself and love who you are
and and all of that until all those
emotions you can apply to yourself I
don't think that you're capable of
applying to others the song - it's about
loving instead of fear and and until you
do that with yourself you're not able to
like I said to apply that to other
relationships in your life and in other
scenarios in your life is there a
specific turning point you can remember
where you didn't really love yourself
and is there a time we can remember
actually starting to fall in love
yourself um this is going to sound so
silly but sometimes it's the silly
circumstances that turn things around
but I was actually in high school and I
was you know I always auditioned for
things and I
really hard I just didn't get this thing
that I was going for and and and
somebody that got it was very beautiful
and very not good at what they were
doing and I was it was kind of a hard
lesson to learn I did everything right I
worked so hard I did it and just because
of my aesthetics I didn't get it and I
and I thought that was such a weird
thing because it wasn't a job for
modeling so um I and I and it kind of
threw me for a loop and I went into this
very like depressed state for like I
don't know a few months of like my high
school life and and you know it seems so
silly now as an adult thinking back but
when you're a kid those things are so
and so huge and I was like so I didn't
get it cuz I wasn't pretty enough or
skinny enough for what enough like I was
like wait what but that wasn't the point
it was a vocal thing and months later I
realized I'm never gonna you know you're
not always gonna get what you want even
if you deserve it and that's okay and
and maybe it wasn't what I was supposed
to get and maybe I've got something else
because it made me work harder so I
think that point I know it sounds
incredibly silly but it was it was a
thing that I kind of learned early on
that everything isn't always fair but
it's just what happens and your
character is what you do with that one
of the knowing things about being in
this industry being this amazing the
street even now even in 2020 less we
look at the Abdal example for instance
like what's happening the last couple
days like oh my god she's also this way
like how amazing there's still so much
pressure let's put on two women to
validate them by look when it's not
[ __ ] in there darlin she was
beautiful
then she's be toward now always gonna be
beautiful how has that changed for you
and how's that discussion I felt more
pressure from people actually when I was
thin like when I was really thin and
like not super healthy like in that
sense because I just was worn out and
just working so hard and not keeping
healthy habits but I felt more pressure
I mean it was more of like you know
magazines shoved in front of you and
like
this is what you're competing with and
we've got to compete with it and I'm
like I can't like I can't compete with
that like that's not even my image like
that's not who I am like that's who they
are that's what art is we're all
different like and it's okay and I
fought more when I was thinner than I do
now cuz now I just walk in and I just
look at him like I dare you to say
something like I'm like I look I'm happy
in my life
I'll work on me and my time and and
that's who I am and that's okay
but I think that honestly it's it's up
to artists to really push back it's up
to people in the limelight to push back
and go look I'm cool with you not being
okay with this but you know this is who
I am
I honestly at my heaviest point I was
hired to be on the voice I got like I'm
the number one television mi like
heaviest point and it's like it's right
after I had kids and it was like you
know they didn't care so I think it's
really up to artists to force people to
have that mentality yeah for sure
say what people like I'm actually just
this is blowing my mind that people
actually split magazines in front of
your face and be like be like this like
naked like that would be like a chick
naked like on the cover like I'm not
joking
like literally make it and I was like
okay unless I'm doing an SNL skit and
this is a comedy thing I'm never gonna
put like even in not because of my
aesthetic like even in my thinnest most
bit moment it's just not my personality
to be like nekkid on the front of a
magazine now mind you I love my husband
will tell you I am totally okay with
nudity I think it is very a beautiful
thing I think all of our bodies like
whether you're male or female we are
very beautiful beings I have no problem
with it but I do have a problem with
someone chasing what they think is
popular and what it's way to get them
played it's kind of like the lessons you
learn in high school and she set you up
to be able to not let this stuff
overwhelm you in later life right it
really did help shape me and shape what
I really care about and I think learning
that lesson early on what really you
know benefited me because I could look
at people and go I don't care how much
money you're gonna offer me I'm not
doing it
I don't want to do that that's not
that's not who I am and it's not who I
wanna be
can you remember saying no to something
and there's what some think one of those
things was and how it then actually
became a really amazing beneficial to be
to say no I do write a lot of my music
but I also love I have great
relationships with writers as well and I
love other writers and I love singing
songs that I don't write so um but there
definitely been many circumstances where
they're like literally I've been called
a stupid B for not recording the songs
you're so stupid I don't understand why
you don't see this you should just shut
up and sing what we tell you to sing and
I'm like okay cool if it was such a mega
hit then why didn't someone else cut it
afterwards and why wasn't it successful
if it was such a great moment of a song
that anybody anybody would be lucky to
have this song you're so lucky that
we're bestowing this gift upon you if it
was such a great hit then how come you
know pink didn't cut it or how come
Avril Lavigne didn't care how about you
know how come Christina didn't cut it
it's just always funny to me like
they'll try and guilt you and and bully
you into a decision and it's like it
cool it might be a hit it's just not
something I want to say it's so amazing
you can sit here today in 2020 in this
crazy well be living in and be so
assured of yourself to have that sense
of self belief like having that South
belief is such a gift isn't there I
think that you know you have that choice
you're either gonna lean into who you
want to be you're gonna lean into what
people say you you are and I don't
believe people I believe me
so that's such a powerful thing you can
even shut out that level of negativity
as well in this world where we have so
many voices but all those voices though
are hurt and you've got to recognize
that all those voices all those people
calling you whatever or you know you're
not good enough or you're not living
your life right and how you should be
like all those people that's their own
demons
that's their own issues like within
themselves and as soon as you recognize
that as soon as you go okay you're being
kind of a word I probably shouldn't
sound zoom um you're being kind of that
person to me right now so I'm gonna
recognize that maybe you weren't hugged
enough
and maybe nobody showed you what a real
you know relationship looks like our
friendship looks like I think it just
really takes recognizing where that
anger and hurt from that person is
coming from it has nothing to do with
you oh my god the shore and then finally
one thing I want to ask you was if you
can stay there you down he was going for
a really hard time and she needed a
piece of ice the most in your life when
with that time of thin and what would
you want to say to her I have a great
mother and in the sense that she's a the
perfect mother for me me calling her I
can think of a situation I was like I
was exhausted and it was I don't know
2005 my mom happened to call me and I
was literally driving myself to the
airport in LA going I'm done like I was
a really good waitress and I'm I'm done
I can't legally I'm so tired of fighting
just to be me it is exhausting she
happened to call me and and I was on my
way to the airport and she didn't know
that and and she happened to say so what
I would say to myself is exactly what my
mother said to me which is why I'm
saying this and she said look then come
home like but you know in some sense
you're quitting like because you're
letting them win so if you can't handle
it then come home and choose a different
path but this at this point all I'm
hearing is you complaining that
everybody's not saying what you want
them to say and you need to tell them
what you want and if they don't listen
you keep telling them you need to stop
complaining you need to stop feeling
sorry for yourself and you turn your car
back around and you need to put your
big-girl panties on and get back in
there and and I I know a lot of people
probably wanted a mom maybe that would
be like oh honey I know like they're so
wrong and they've wronged you I don't
need that kind of mom I needed exactly
the mom that I got I would be my mom I
mean my daughter will tell you that I'm
pretty hardcore mom too so I I mean I
I'm pretty much like that as well so I
would tell myself exactly what my mother
told me and I'm very grateful for her my
god you put those big out knickers on
because you got it
I forgot the chocolate knickers that's
my favorite things we're giving you
cleavage will give you knickers oh not
even God
could give me cleavage at this point but
thank you I'd have to pay for that man I
told my mom if I ever my mom and sister
I said if I ever get in some major
accident where I'm just like wrecked and
they have to go in and do a bunch of
plastic surgery if I don't wake up with
a nice set of sees I'm gonna be so mad
I'm gonna be so mad cuz at that point
I'm already under and I deserve it right
like I'm just like this it's not fair
I've already gotten his horrible wreck
and I might not survive it but if I
survive it and I wake up with these
anybody still I'm gonna be so mad that's
the only way I would ever do because I'm
terrified
my friends will get stuff done and I'm
just terrified oh yeah I'm just gonna
look like a shar-pei dog I'm just gonna
get old and wrinkly and it's fine turn
and you are stunning
shopping of a stunning check
you